wow 100 miles this looks like impossible
but not because of course it will be out
but if she know why you are here if it's
a dream
I'm sure it's possible to do
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast my
guest today is one of the greatest some
might even say the greatest ultra
distance Trail runners in the world his
name is Francois Dan and although that
name might not be quite as ubiquitous as
that of Killian jornays at least outside
of the insular Ultra World make no
mistake this man who calls the Alps home
is just an absolute Beast among his
countless achievements Francois has won
UTMB the world's most prestigious Trail
Ultra four times a record only recently
matched by Killian himself this year
setting course records twice in 2017
France wall clock the fastest ever
Traverse of the 210 mile John Muir Trail
and in 2021 Francois won the Hard Rock
100 one of if not the most difficult
Trail Ultras breaking the overall record
previously held by Killian
Beyond his career as a professional
athlete Francois is a physiotherapist
he's a family man he's a father of three
children as well as a wine maker and a
couple months ago I had the privilege to
meet to hang out with and host a live
conversation with Francois in Boulder
Colorado as part of an event hosted by
Solomon the sponsor we both chair and
the next day it was followed up by the
podcast conversation you are now about
to enjoy Beyond his Mastery of ultra
running what really strikes me most
about Francois is his really low-key
humble and grounded approach to his
craft how he manages to strike This
truly healthy balance between the rigors
of pursuing that Mastery and the
importance of enjoying life enjoying
family community and other interests
outside of sport altogether
in addition to covering his path to
Excellence we discussed the principles
that drive his Peak Performance
longevity we talk about the details of
his training regimen we discuss advice
for tackling your first Ultra and many
other topics I should say up front that
Francoise French accent can be a bit
thick at times but if you listen closely
you should be just fine and be sure to
make sure the captions are playing on
YouTube here so you can catch every word
so with that please enjoy my
conversation with Francois Dan
[Music]
good well
um thank you for doing this it's so nice
to meet you I can't wait to learn about
your life I'm excited to talk to you and
uh here we are in a running store in
Boulder Colorado doing this podcast old
school on the road and uh yeah uh how
you doing today how are you feeling how
are you
um getting your head straight for the
big hard rock 100 yes
to make it to the US again and I really
I really enjoy this part of the of the
season and of the year and since uh yes
two years I
I'm so happy to to build my season and
until June where I moved to Colorado and
um yeah this year will be a will be
special for sure too and already today
because I'm so happy to to discuss with
you I I fully beat your
your life and your different podcast and
it's always interesting to have a yeah
it's kind of a different approach of
running and it's a it's amazing to to be
there to discuss with you I appreciate
that and you know and kind of reflecting
on your life and and your career
um obviously you're one of the greatest
of all time in in trail running
um for UTMB wins you won Hard Rock last
year
set the record you're going into Hard
Rock again coming up in in a very short
period of time here
um
and my sense is that you're very
celebrated in Europe but that in the
United States or in North America
perhaps less so so I have a very
specific agenda for this podcast which
is to help raise awareness of your
amazing talents and uh your own careers
so that is too big no no well it's an
it's an interesting moment because I
think that the interest in trail running
and adventure racing you know is on the
rise very much so people are getting
into it and it's just growing at an
explosive rate right now
um and so I think that you know North
America is very primed to learn more
about your life and you know how you've
been able to do the things that that you
do
yeah it's it's and it's happy to discuss
about that but hey it's it's a bit
patchy specific because there's always a
yes like a comparison between
Europe and North America and
everybody thinks that in U.S and Europe
everybody think it's totally different
try running in U.S is totally different
than traveling in Europe or in France
and for me not at all we just uh we are
just happy to be in the mundane and you
have some very nice and specific
maintain here and in France too in
Europe too so for me it's just
about be be fascinated to to spend some
long day in the mountain and to listen
about yourself to try to
yeah to to be the better part of you in
the mountain for some long day so
yeah for me it's not uh being an
American runner I've been European
Runner is just being a mundane Runner
and uh that's why I'm so happy to to to
discuss with American runner and to
share my experience with them because
it's always a it's always interesting
and funny to to see with the media and
other people are kind of right can
discuss about that that that that seems
like maybe that's an American thing like
here in America we're thinking oh we
have a certain way of training but what
are those guys over there doing and that
helps they're living in small villages
and they're just going out you know way
up into high elevation every single day
and perhaps you know because we don't
have access to those types of mountains
that there's something to your lifestyle
uh or your kind of relationship with
training that is very different than the
way that the Americans approach it and
I've I've heard you say like you kind of
disabuse people of this notion you're
like no it's not actually that different
but your friend Jim Walmsley you know
seems to be under that impression which
is why he moved to France feeling like
that is the missing ingredient in his
ability to you know kind of win UTMB
like he had to go and immerse himself in
that culture and that lifestyle
we'll see but uh no I think yeah
yeah I think it could be interesting to
discuss with him but I think it's it's
not just about the immersion in the
French Arab and French Montana will make
the difference it's maybe more is an
approach of the event and while his
approach of his training and I'm sure he
can he can do the same training in in us
and have the same approach if it takes
time for that but I'm thinking Flagstaff
it's very warm it's a bit more flat than
in in France but I'm sure that in
Silverton you can train uh even better
than in France for for a race like UTMB
but uh it for me it's very very
interesting it's very nice to have him
just like 200 meters from his house so
we can share some very good Training and
moment and I really appreciate him
better as those American runner it's
always nice to yes to show culture to
share some very good moment and uh yeah
I try to to discover a bit more the U.S
culture because I I like it and they
like European culture because I think
it's something like normal that we are
always more interesting about what is
different from what we are are used for
and for me it's very interesting to to
discuss with American runner I was there
I think the first time in 2012 but since
10 years now I'm I'm always always so
happy to to came back in us because I
always learned some different thing and
and I'm always impressed about how how
big this country and everything and the
trident
in in Europe and Friends some of the
longest rights it's 100 miles and I was
like four years ago the beginning of the
Pacific Crest right it's 4 500 right
okay it's just
unbelievable so from it's amazing to be
there yeah I I think you know correct me
if I'm wrong the sense is that
in the United States people who are
trying to train at a certain level
um kind of complicate things or get
really into data and spreadsheets and
get very much up in their head about how
to approach these races whereas a
European
sensibility is more like we live in
these small villages we keep our our
lives are very you know kind of less
complex in that regard and and we keep
things like kind of very basic and you
know I do feel like there's some shared
DNA with somebody like Killian who you
know will tell you like it's just about
your relationship with nature and it's
about being outdoors and the humility
and the experience of you know pushing
your body and just being alone you know
with the Majesty of the mountains which
is a different relationship I think to
Performance than the kind of American
mindset
yeah yeah you're right I think but it's
uh yeah
it's yes it's not not all of the
European I like that and also American I
like that too but I think it's more
about an ultra approach because I think
when it's more short distance it's it
could be totally different but on
neutral distance the approach I think
must be different and I cannot speak for
Killian but I think it's a bit same as
me it's not that we okay we want to be a
top Runner a neutral mundane and so we
have to do that now
we we did that and because of that maybe
we became some good Ultra Runner but
it's it's totally different that I want
to became a good entrepreneur so I have
to do that just say
anyway I do that so maybe I can became a
good returner or not but anyway we want
to spend some long day in the mountain
we want to be there we want to train
like that we want to have this kind of
life
and just uh
I think the the loveras
performance is just a consequence right
our life and and I can think that's the
approach of some American Runners maybe
a bit different I would like to
to win you 10B maybe one day or
something that's I have to train like
that I have to do that I have to do that
and it's not it's not I think the same
the same way the beginning must be okay
I I'd like I would like to be in the
mountain I would like to experience
myself I would like to push my limits to
discover that kind of trade of that kind
of mundane
and then the consequence will be that ah
because of that life because of that
training you will be sure in front of
the scene and for short distance I think
it's not the same thing okay I want to
be a performer on short distance in
Golden train whatever you want okay so I
have to focus on my training I have to
be professional and I like to do that
that and then you have the result but I
think it's it's too many things it's
okay it's the training it's a
performance it's a body but
first is the mentality it's approach
it's our train and I I know
I know well I think cotton in the water
you made a few register some postcard
and I think
she's one of those who have this kind of
approach she don't take care about the
result of the race I don't think what
she like is to be out out in the
mountain to spend some long day and then
if she can make some race she's so happy
and and finally the result is just the
consequence of what she did all along
the year she she don't focus on One race
or another race if it's not working on
One race okay no it's it's not good but
no worry she have another race another
plan and anywhere she's so happy to
train for that so it's not the same
approach and I try to discuss a lot with
Jim about that because uh if his
approach is okay I would like to be the
first American runner to want to win new
champion
it's pretty sure it's really I I hope
you will be able to do that because it's
a an amazing Runner is very very good
but the approach is wise it's odd for me
I think if I have that kind of approach
it's impossible for me to to win a race
right right right so essentially what
you're saying is in the long run
especially with these longer distance
Mountain races
um
uh you know achieving goals only comes
at the as a consequence of the lifestyle
that you live as opposed to being very
kind of driven towards a specific result
and I I've heard you say
um I think it was with respect uh maybe
it was uh UTMB last year like the
question was like how do you shoulder
the pressure of going into UTMB like
you've won three times can you do it
again uh you know that must be
overwhelming and you said something like
well
if I win great but if I don't you know
I'll take my kids to you know go do
something and I have a whole life
outside of this and and that was what
kind of made me think of the the
difference in sensibility of you know
kind of a European mindset versus an
American mindset whereas the American
would be devastated if they lost and
they're like they're clenching their
fists and you know trying to drive kind
of will a certain result as so it's it's
it's like the difference between
self-will versus like being in the
allowing right like if I'm I'm living my
lifestyle I'm allowing the result to
unfold that is meant to be as a result
of the decisions that I've made about
how I live my life yeah it's true it's
even more easy for me to say that when
you will need free time right it's true
okay you don't have pressure but you
won't need free time so easy to say that
okay sure but for me even the first time
if I arrive at the start line with this
kind of pressure I'm sure
I I'm I won't able to finish because I I
want to protect myself and I as as to
someone I don't want to have this kind
of pressure so I'm I'm at the start line
and say okay I have a very good Training
I have some two very good months and I'm
so happy to be there
if I can win if I can finish truth on
the podium whatever it's it's so so good
so I will be so happy but yeah but if
not
it's okay it's just a spot it's just a
pleasure right and my life will continue
and I will have some other possibility
and some other chance but for me it's
take like 20 years maybe to arrive
at the start line with this position and
without any pressure and and it's not
easy every day every day you have to
work on yourself and to say it again and
that's why I don't want to go back like
each year on the same race like for me
this year
going back to Hard Rock 100 again just
when you're after where you finish first
when you break the record I was not
expected that last year I was thinking
okay it's just an experience for me next
year I will come back and I will do it
better but last year
I finish and say how can I do it better
so this year you came back with a bit of
pressure because even for yourself you
cannot say okay I will be there just to
try to finish a command like last year
you win you break the record you are not
just you have to finish so for me this
year it's it's bit more pressure but uh
that's why I try to to uh that's why I
try to have another approach to say okay
I'm here
last year it was just incredible I was
lucky so I'm Ill again so it's
it's so good I'm so lucky too so it's
another way it's another race there's
another Runner so yes I will I will I
would like just to to finish it and to
it just yeah we are just 160 runner at
the start line so I'm so lucky to be
there
it's a huge community of ultra dry
runner in us it's just like a family
everybody has swipey to to meet each
other like even tonight in Boulder I
think it will be so nice to have a like
a common event and probably I say okay I
have please enjoy it and don't push your
pressure on yourself and read that way
I'm sure the race will be will be good
right it's such a healthy strategy and
one that has longevity to it right
because you're you're you're releasing
yourself from like carrying that burden
it's like confidence in the preparation
gratitude for just being able to be
there and be healthy and participate and
also kind of a healthy respect with for
all the variables that you don't control
the weather and other people and all
that kind of stuff right like the longer
the race the less control you actually
have you just have you know the
preparation that you that you endure
just to get there and you know I was
listening to your
conversation with Dylan Bowman
um you guys were talking about Hard Rock
last year and and and how you were you
know you were kind of you know running
near each other and and realizing that
you were like way ahead the the record
that Killian had said and thinking maybe
perhaps we've made a terrible error yeah
exactly
it all worked out but then thinking well
how can I do better this year and saying
well maybe I don't have to worry about
that I'm just here to experience the
community and uh to do my best
um and I think the community piece is
also really interesting I know that last
year was the first
running of Hard Rock in three years
because of covid and also uh you know
weather conditions prior to that but you
would come to Silverton in 2019
nonetheless uh you know engage with the
community train on the the course and
kind of you know now you've become kind
of part of that that community that
you're returning to tomorrow
yay Keith was it was very nice in 2019
to be able to be there and we have some
very good moments and we discover the
race without any pressure we've choser
it was very very interesting there's a
lot of snow so it was so it's very
interesting to play in the snow because
like people like gyms they just learn
how to run in the snow four years ago so
it was very interesting for me to
discuss about that with them
and yeah it's it should be a
should be very interesting and it's it's
not a good thing that did and woman
won't race this year because that's here
we have an incredible day as a
Evan frame I think he was not expecting
when
so fast at that base and yes during all
the race we are thinking uh maybe we're
out too fast but anyway we have a very
good day so we continue do you think
about the other competitors I I texted
Dylan yesterday and I said uh I'm going
to be talking to Francois like what what
would be you know interesting for me to
explore with him that is something I
can't Google or find out online and he's
like I'm so fascinated by Francois
relationship with competition and we've
already kind of covered a little bit of
your sensibility with that
um but you seem so uh it's really not
about like what anyone else is doing
right like in the longer the race is the
less it is about you know some other
performer it's just about your
relationship with you and the terrain
yeah yeah it's exactly that's
um I I am I don't take care about those
are Runner even before the race
Heaven normally during the race but but
I'm a bit competitor so when I'm doing
the Race I I really like and enjoy to
play with the other Runner but it's not
my main goal for sure do you think about
like oh I know this Runner uses this
strategy so I have to look out for that
or do you not pay attention to any of
them no I I know that and I play with
that and I yeah you have time to finish
in 24 hours so you can think okay maybe
this Runner is going too fast because I
know him so I I don't have to take care
about that but you you play with that
but you have to your main focus must be
on you otherwise it's I think it's too
hard on neutral trial and that's why I I
really like you'll charge right running
it's totally different from the other
distance I think even songs 100K now and
even more I think less than
like Western States time it's for Jim
it's around like 40 an hour I think yeah
I think more than 14 hours it's another
world right so less than 14 hour I think
now competitors are yes well experienced
the train for that they are very like
I think less than 14 hours it's more
like Athletics and race
more than 14 16 hour I think it's it's
another world and more than 20 hours
again something else
so I think it's it's very important to
have a different approach and that's why
I
think I'm still there after like
my first long distance was 2006 I think
so it's 12 years ago and normally you
you cannot make a such long carrier in
in high performance in sport right but
if I'm still there it's maybe because
this is the spot totally different and
we're experienced
helps you a lot and approach helps you a
lot and yes that's why I think I still
continue to progress even if now I'm
maybe too old for that yeah but I really
enjoy that and I think the experience is
something just
interesting in Ultra yeah I mean there
is a long history in ultra running where
somebody will burst onto the scene and
they'll have unbelievable performances
for maybe two years three years and then
whether it's over training or burnout or
whatever it is they're unable to ever
kind of match that level again like you
don't see very many people who have
longevity in their careers yeah it's
it's so sad for me and that's why I have
this kind of a brush and I try to push
that kind of approach through the media
because I'm so sad when I saw some
Runner just say okay I will try to do
six or seven neutral try in a year or
even four to three in a year or even in
France I have some amazing owners okay
we'd like to do like a you Champion
Diego and some of the race
and now it's I think it's too much maybe
it could be one year like last year I I
tried to to running back to back uh
artwork 100 and new Team B it's only six
weeks but it was my
only goal for the Euro and I prepared
that one since three years and I run
since 25 Euros so it's not just okay you
do it last year next year you can do
snow right it's something very special
and I I won't do it again this year and
I think for Kian you will try to do it
this year and even seriously not at the
middle but it's Kian it runs since since
he was born yeah so it's it's not
everybody can do that because uh if you
miss and do that I think
in a year and it's two hour
and for us it's 24 hours so how can we
do more than two race right and I see so
many many Runners even American runner
when I start in 2012 they were there and
now it's so hard for them I think about
like rope cross and people
Jeff Rose or some people like that even
unturned it's zero is a race and maybe
sometimes too much and then it was too
hard to recover
and they were so good and I think maybe
they get to a train or too much too much
pressure or something like that and then
it's too hard for the body to came back
so right so we have to be really really
really relaxed about that and we discuss
a lot with Jim about that and this year
that's why
he did a race in upgrade and then it's
okay now I just focus on YouTube MB and
maybe it will be nicer and I think ah
it's a very good approach and I like it
because
you will be very fresh and I'm sure that
next year you will be there again and
this is the most important for me
winning a race it's important but be
able to
to run again in five years I think it's
the most important thing for us and for
our body yeah sure I mean I think that
the the sport is maturing in terms of
how people are understanding training
and performance those Runners that you
mentioned and even the generation prior
to that like very little was known
because people were pushing the
boundaries of the distances that anybody
thought humans could even run to begin
with and so of course the mentality was
like well if we can do that let's train
more let's train more and then suddenly
all of these people you know are kind of
falling off the Wayside but we saw Anton
come back after that long you know
period of absence so I think there is
that POS now it's like oh well if you
were one of those people maybe you can
rebuild in a new and different way it
was so nice to see see him again and I I
chat with him yesterday because I know
it he did not so far from there and he's
a bit focus on bicycle yeah
foreign
[Music]
okay
but yeah it was so nice to see him again
and yeah on Tunnel even joke around I'm
sure I will see see him in in Iraq in
two days it's so nice to continue to
discuss with them every year uh I'm
swiping to meet uh Anna frost and she
was here even before me in the try
running community and it's so nice to
see that that kind of people okay
they'll swap people their performance
and about their their carrier and which
race that we was able to win but they
are even more happy to be still there
and still able to run and if you discuss
with them they will I'm sure 100 that
they would say is the most important
thing is just be able to be again in the
mountain today to be able to have some
Long Bay and to share some nice win with
the people in the community it's even
more important than winning that race or
the race or pushing too much for that
because in 20 years what what will you
what will you remember
I was able to do that but now I'm not I
don't want to run anymore I don't want
to be in the mountain right I'm not
passionated about that well okay I did
that but I'm still there and I'm still
so happy and so passionated to do that
and for me is the most important thing
that okay remaining joyful about the
whole I I just want to be there in in
five or ten years with my kids and to
say okay I'm so happy to share with you
this Looper and Montblanc
you know kids I was there in Silverton
like 20 years ago and now I'm still
there with you and I'm able to made a
loop of night work ah it's I think it's
my biggest dream actually even more than
winning again a race it's just too busy
in 10 years and to say hey I'm in there
and I can share it with you it's wow
this is for me the most important thing
that's all fine but come on let's get
honest here I don't want to make you
uncomfortable but like fourth UTMB wins
I mean there's got to be a killer under
the surface they're like what why are
you so much better than everyone else
[Music]
weapon like what are you doing that
others aren't doing or or how are you
you know
built physiologically so that you are so
exceptional at this sport
I've I don't know just that I'm so
passionate either when uh when you you
know when when you are the start line it
should be like like we speak or speak
earlier
when you are the start line you just you
don't feel the pressure you just feel as
a poorer just to say wow I'm here I wait
that moment since two years and I'm here
so everybody say oh you how you can do
one or two nights without sleeping how
can I sleep I wait that moment since two
years I'm so excited I'm so happy to be
there and then it's like you have you
have rings so you can you can fly around
the mountain and I'm so happy and and
then if the race goes like you won't
then you're okay it would be sunsets and
rice
that would be this bus is so
unbelievable and then ah you can feel
your sensation you can feel your
training you can feel what you built
since 10 years your strategy about food
about that lamp about equipment about
material about family but everything
there's a lot of thing
and when everything match
wow then you feel okay today I'm
I'm perfect day and you don't feel it
and even like I think last year in our
work I was even more fast at the end at
the beginning just because I was wow
today it's just so incredible and I
remember with Dakota Jones we play in
the he pays me at the as the rest on the
last button we're just playing and we
run all all over all the time I say okay
I'm even faster than at the beginning
it's just crazy and just no matter if
it's 10 20 25 hours you just you're just
happy and then you you can you can feel
it that you yeah you are just flying and
it's just a very good moment and yeah
it's this is what I I've I try to this
kind of sense of feelings I try to have
a
on a race right your emotional
relationship to the whole thing but as
somebody who you you have a background
in physiotherapy right so from like a
biological perspective or a training
perspective like are you
uh doing things in training that you
think others aren't or is there
something about your the way that you're
you're built like Killian has a crazy
VO2 max or you know is there something
that makes you extra well suited to this
type of sport or do you think it's just
because you've been doing it for a long
time and like I don't know like I'm
trying to wrap my head around like what
I'm sure there are other people that
participate in these races who are very
grateful to be there right and have a
love for the mountains so there is
something different going on with you is
there not no it's true
I'm trying to make you blush scientific
approach it's true that uh yes I cannot
complain about my performance and about
my body but I think I I have a tradition
and I think it's a bit different because
he tried to be to perform on short
distance and long distance so and I
think it's not a it's not a secret that
Kian have some incredible uh
capacity and ability in terms of Earth
and race and everything very high level
of exertion and and me I practice like
at 18 like 3000 Steeplechase when I was
young or cross country and uh I was not
bad but I was not at the top level and I
think okay I can run fast but not uh not
as
yes I was not very very good at not the
top French performer but I think it was
enough for Ultra trial existence and so
I'm not uh I don't train just for ultra
try distance because during winter I
made some intensity and something that
had not as Killian but more than
ninety percent of people which practice
on the ultra trial in France or even in
Europe or U.S I think so I think I I
during winter I work a lot on my
physiology and on intensity and
something like that so I think I
uh
it's not it's not too compared to Kian
because it's something different but if
I compare some to the to the other long
long distance ultra distance Runner I
think uh on short distance I'm I could
be better than them but uh what I like
is the same approach as them it's been
some long day in the mountains like I
I've even more so I think I can have the
same endurance training than them but if
I want to push I can push a bit
a bit higher than them so it was
interesting like last year in ugmb I
think we have the same background with
the five or six other Runner but because
we play too much with Jim Wamsley I was
just so destroyed after 80k and in the
distance it was hard for me to go fast
but I know that if I want to push in
each ascent I can I can make like four
or five minutes
faster than the user so it was so
comfortable for me if I'm not
comfortable because painful but it was
very interesting for me to say okay even
if I lose three minutes in each decent
it's it's not so bad because I I can
easily put them five or four minutes in
each Essence so I think for me it's uh
it's very interesting to have this
background just to know that okay in
neutral distance I maybe like the other
but if I want to push I can push a bit
more you have that extra gear so you
yeah in your back pocket you have the
confidence to know like it's fine I'm
running with you right now because when
we get to that grade up there
I can go
so let's talk about the training a
little bit uh uh you know is there what
is the structure to it what is the the
philosophy of the day in day out
approach you know what is it you know
walk us through what that looks like
yeah so if I I try to have a long-term
approach on my training and on my race
and on my carrier event
so I don't have a like a day-to-day
running I I don't like to have any
routine and I can't because I built my
life like totally different that normal
Runner or professional Runner because uh
you know what
what it means to have some kids but we
have three kids we have like now nine
seven and three years old and I it's
amazing you have time to do anything I
want to be there with them and with my
wife we are we we want to have some
common project about the wine about
catching an event about different things
so it's
it's what I want it's not just okay uh
you can just be a professional no yes if
I want I can be a professional Runner
and if I don't want any kids we can make
these shows me better but we don't want
that we want to have a normal life a
social life we want to have kids a
family story we want to have a real job
and to spend some time with that dog
then
okay I know that so I I have to train
when I have time and I know that uh yes
before luck I will have to spend some
long day in the mountains so that's why
I'm here like two weeks before all the
race that's why I will live in Rainier
Island like two reasons Before the Race
because I have to race to beat myself I
have to focus more on my training but uh
but yes I I just know that uh okay two
months before a long race you have to
spend more long day in the mountain you
have to train specifically for for each
or each phrase like for artwork I I know
that's one of the most important thing
is Altitude training so I
I don't want that much uh like during
since the last two months but I spend a
lot of time in I maintain so it was
schemo it was in clean being it was
something like that and I think if I
compared to last year I run even less
but I spend more time in high altitude
so I I think it's it's maybe a good
thing for hard work and if I have to go
to Virgin Island at the end of the year
I know that uh it's totally different
and I will have to focus more like on
this and training something like that to
there's a lot of stairs in that island
so I have to to work with big steps or
something like that and I I try to think
like six months or five months before
the race okay what will be specific on
that of that race and then every day
every unite every training you think
about that okay what I'm actually doing
it's important for next race or it's no
matter so I try to don't do that right
right and yes and then I have yes I try
to respect a lot the the season and the
the condition uh in the mundane saw
that's why I choose that kind of season
actually that's starting my running
session with hard rock 100 it's just
perfect for me because uh there's a lot
of snow from like December to May where
I live so it's hard to be ready for a
racing up Freedom maybe because uh it
means that you have to take the car to
go in the valley to train and this isn't
what I it's not what I love it's what I
love is running for my drawer or skiing
from my drawer yeah so it's easier for
me to to make some to practice some
schema
from January to May and I think it's a
very very good Training for endurance
training and for Ultra strategy for
summer then you have to back on running
slowly and progressively and I have all
of them all the months of April May and
June to back on running progressively so
it's just perfect for race like mid July
so that's why I choose that kind of
strategy since
three to four years now right just
because I know okay if I have to train
in March in running
it will be out from to get the
motivation and monetary so that's why I
try to adapt my strategy like that and
to think like long time ago with my wife
with my friends with my partner but my
calendar is okay I will do it next year
so I have to focus mid July I have to
focus mid-october so I have to plan
everything around that so even about you
know the product development the family
events the socials the holidays
everything I try to plan it like in
November and December and then it's
it's razier to train into everything
because uh with my family we know we
know with the kids and the family since
last year since one month one year ago
that I will leave the families as well
yeah exactly end of June it's not like
if I say to them one week ago it would
be a sword for them but no since when
you're reprie browser since one year we
know that okay it will be out for them
and for me to be without each other
during three weeks so we have to plan
some strategies they will visit uh some
friends some families they will have
some stage they will have some different
thing I will prepare many things so it's
easier and we wait that moment finally
and we will be so happy to meet each
other in three weeks so it just if if
you plan it since one year or even more
it's it's so easy but if you don't say
to your people around you okay see you
later in one month I have a my biggest
race of my life and bye bye
so this is my it's not like I don't know
if I own very well to your question it's
not my uh strategic of training but but
planning things like that
I think it's it's a key point of the
training because then you just have to
say Okay we respect we bring we keep
some free time for that we we plan C7 or
z77 and finally your training training
is nearly done like that because now I'm
here two weeks and I'll be for artwork
I finish all my product development I'm
just without family I just have time for
me what will you do when you are in the
mountain just with free time for you
it's training so it's easy to train so
there is a there is something
uh counter-intuitive but but kind of
undeniable about
um having a full life outside of your
life as an athlete you know you would
think you would you would enhance your
performance by living like a monk in a
cabin alone and just waking up in the
morning and going out and training all
day with no distractions year round and
perhaps you could get a great
performance in the short term but you
know the more I speak to you the more I
realize how deeply you think about
longevity like it's more about trying to
be the best that you can be for the
longest period of time and in order to
do that you have to have uh diversity in
your life you have to be living your
life
um you can't be putting aside things
that you want in your life for the sake
of performance so to have three kids to
have you know this full life where
you're engaging your community and you
know your your previous career as a wine
maker which I want to talk about out
like all of those things feel like they
would detract from your performances but
my sense is that all of those things
ultimately you know enhance your
performance they fuel your life because
you're a happy grounded person with
interests outside of just running
it's true but uh it's true too that you
are more tired and it's not easy to
train every day and some I actually it
was a I have a very elements of months
of June and I discuss with us with Jim
and say okay
okay don't have any kids he's just in
friends for training yeah just to wake
up maybe it's coffee and then thinking
oh where can I go today to train and you
you wake up at six in the morning
because baby is crying then you have to
take kids to school then you have to
have enough email and part there and
media to do and then if you have time
you can go to train but you have too
many things to do okay it's too much how
can I performed like that but on those
other things you think about what you
sense okay this is my life I choose that
one
and it's helped me a lot so it's it's
it's never easy to
towards this background and to have a
but I think for me every everybody is
different but for me it was very
important since the beginning and we
discussed a lot of that with my wife to
have a balanced life to have this
different pillar so the case of family
social
jobs the sport everything and and sport
is important but for me I try to never
put it like a most important thing in my
life
I always try to have some back windows
okay it's it's just a pleasure it's just
a passion and and I think having kids
and something for me are
we was always more important for than
everything because uh if you focus too
much on sport okay one year it's it's
everything works okay it's perfect but
if it's doing 10 years then 10 years you
you look uh you look beside you or you
look around you it's okay since then you
know I focus on that and finally I don't
have any kids and I don't read
everything from me I think it's what
your whole sense of idea is wrapped up
in in your performances
yeah I think yeah yeah
um
with respect to the training I've heard
you say uh something along the lines of
it's more important like the the the the
frequency of your trainings is more
important than like the length of your
trainings like there's this idea if
you're going to be an ultra Runner you
got to go out and run for 12 hours a day
every single day right and I think
you've said like your longer runs are
really kind of in the you know six to
seven hour range you'll go out for those
longer days of as you mentioned earlier
just being in the mountain schema or
just you know kind of hiking or whatever
it is to experience altitude but in
terms of the running my sense is that
you're careful not to overdo it and go
into that kind of over training Zone
where you can get injured or burn out I
try tuba to uh you always have some pain
or somewhere I have an extra yeah some
some difficulty with some part of my
body but I try to
to make some cycling and to make
different things and I I try to to never
put too much uh through your training or
Android so yes I I try to do that but uh
yes I it's it's it's kind of part of my
training too to say okay I wake up uh my
second kid they wake up like eight times
each night until you have three years
so you can you can say okay I'm too
Taiwan and I cannot train or you can say
okay I will trade training when you're
in here is kind of a good thing but yes
I was thinking that I was thinking okay
I'm so tired but I have to train but
when you are in a neutral after 20 hours
what do you think you are tired too so
if you never train when you are tired
you will never have this feeling some
you say okay I will I will train with
less intensity of course maybe with less
energy of course but I will train anyway
even if I'm tired even if I win too much
the day before if I met too much party
even okay it's even if I eat too much
even if just I have my breakfast okay
you have to test everything because in
neutral you will meet everything and in
Ultra what we say earlier is that uh you
cannot you can plan everything
but you will to adapt you will have to
adapt everything yeah because uh this is
why we made Ultra if we know what will
happen we can make athletes more
cross-country or some Loop but no we we
go in the mountain in I mean 10
uh just because we want to have some
something different we we will have to
adapt ourselves and that's why I think
my life maybe it's good for ultra
distance because uh okay this morning we
are in U.S uh we want to try your
scumbers from their eggs and bacon and
everything but then okay you will run
okay but I won't have to wait three
hours for running
and I have to train directly so okay I
feel Evie okay I feel uh thirsty okay I
feel a bit uh tired about the jet lag
okay but if I have to weigh that
everything is correct right okay I will
run in one week so no it's not good so
okay yesterday we arrived we have a
24-hour day of traveling but okay I'm in
Boulder I'm so happy to be there I I
would like to discover the private
returns so I I go there for a two hour
run for sure I don't have the best
feeling of my life even the worst
feeling of my right ring bunny I sweared
a lot I don't have any any power but but
this is the thing this is the thing and
this is really a good training I think
for Ultra because you have to adapt you
have to feel what's happening in your
body how you can answer and re-adapt and
made things and finally I was able to
run two hours
and I think it's it's a good thing but
if your Wildlife is well planned it will
always be at the best possibility for
your training
when you arrive in an ultra you don't
you're waiting for a long time you don't
know how to do right right you're
missing the whole point yeah and of
course when you arrive in Korea after uh
10 hour middle of the night
of course your legs are destroyed of
course you run 10 hour too fast we've
with decent ascent and then it's middle
of the night of course you feel tired
and you don't know what's happened
because you don't want to eat of course
because it's middle of the night nobody
is at the middle of the night yeah so
you don't feel comfortable but if your
body
was never in that in that position he
don't know how to do but if your body
was okay I remember
I did that or I have this same feeling
uh okay I can do it because I I have no
experience that I can then you continue
and then you can
be a better part of yourself and even
won the race but
that's why I think my life is not
finally so bad for virtual training
right maybe for artists and performers
to shop distance training but for Ultra
every training session so you're
combating an obstacle right just to get
out the door exactly yeah that that is a
really interesting lens to look at it
um how has how has your your training
evolved over the years I mean with every
win or miss you know all of these
accomplishments you're learning along
the way and I assume like refining
figuring out what works for you what
what doesn't like did you do anything
different this year leading up to Hard
Rock versus leading up to Hard Rock last
year yeah of course I try to uh normally
I never did a race uh from one year to
to the next year directly because uh you
have two too many elements of comparison
and it's too hard for me and you put too
too much pressure but uh
but it's it's a bit the game of the hard
work one and when you want it then it's
interesting to come to come back the
year after because you you run with the
other way uh for the community I think
it's it's very nice to come back and I'm
so happy to be there again so I have to
to compose with that but uh yes last
year I feel that uh the altitude
training is something very important
was really focused a bit more on that
and I try to build some project around
Montblanc which is which is the highest
mountain in Europe
but the condition was not so good this
year because it was really dry
so I made some more some rock climbing
we go to in Switzerland and in Italy I I
came in seven I don't know if you know
this mountain but it's a very unique
Mountain
and we spent some more than 20 hour
above than four thousand meters and I
did more blinds chemo and I trained a
lot like that so I think about the
Artisan training I'm better than last
year
but uh just about training I think uh
because it's it's alive and we we try to
create an event with my wife for next
September as first edition so
I was not uh thinking that it will take
this amount of time to us and so I don't
have a
I don't have the time that I was
thinking to have for training for just
for running so I think I I'm a bit less
less trained than last year in in
training and even more in distance
because uh because of the we we enjoy to
spend many times around this event and
to discuss about that and we really want
to make something
yes something good and something a very
linked with our values so it was very
important for us it was some one of our
priority uh this past two months so I
hope I will it will be okay and we still
have like 10 days for training so I I
hope it will be okay but I think that uh
I'm I'm well trained on altitude but
less trained I see just in the running
capacity right got it so yes you have
this new race that you and your wife
have created called Ultra Spirit Ultra
Spirit which is coming up in September
early September right yes
um which is exciting you're creating
your own race like it's a couple races
between 25 and 50 kilometers in your
region where you live uh and this is a
new kind of entrepreneurial Journey uh
prior to that you were a wine maker
which I want to get into but like what
inspired you to create your own race
that's a bit uh like a consequence of
why we stop the winery uh and yes for us
it was really important to it's not
really a race it's more like an event I
think a much ultra distance because we
we were thinking okay
um like in five years or ten years if we
want to do something in the mountain uh
something organized in the mountain what
it will be and we were thinking I'm not
sure we go again in UTMB maybe yes I'm
not sure we'll go again a classic ultra
trial I think we we would like to to be
together to share something like as a
team we would like to have some good
moments with the other participant even
with the organizer we would like to be
like in total immersion with the
territory and the
specialty and and we we won't like to to
discover like very very deeply the place
where we are and to to have some fun
uh like the basics which is really tried
so we say okay we have to organize
something like
we can we can answer to that and we were
thinking just okay
what what we what could be very nice for
us in five years to have and then we
organize that event yeah and so it's a
it's a team based that's right like 25
teams three people on a team yeah is it
like a relay or are you running together
with your teammates you start together
and you finish together and you sleep
together and you eat together and you
sleep in a tent of three people without
any shower doing two days so it will be
a reality it should be a very nice
experience for free people but uh with
the team between the team too I think
because this year we start just with 25
team and I think there will be some very
good uh
relationship in the in the in the bee
work and it will be interesting and one
thing interesting too is that that okay
performance is important and the time
uh time of running will be important too
but I think what is the most important
is to to be in the mundane to discover
yourself to discover your team to
discover each other so that's why
everybody will win the same amount of
time
so you will start uh the Friday for six
hours then you will have 11 hours on
Saturday and then you are five hour
again on the Sunday so it will be around
20 21 hour of running during the weekend
which is not nothing but it's not like
21 hour in one time and uh everybody
will win the same amount of time which
is a very difficult for us as organizer
because uh you have to think that the
first team will run faster than the last
year so they will made some like uh
different Loop to arrive all together at
the end like we would like that people
arrive in less than 30 minutes so it
will be very interesting to to organize
it and uh yeah I hope it will be it
would be fun for the people and we will
make some different activity at the
middle like uh you arrive at the top on
the mountain and you will have to to
made a game to just to
to understand what is the difference
between the summer cheese and a winter
cheese which is impossible
uh at the middle of a race but then if
you are not able to do that you will
have a penalty of 25 minutes
yes uh people will say okay no matter if
I went fast or not I must have to focus
on my taste and so it will be
interesting because you will have like
10 games like that wings or three days
that's cool and during the day during
the night and I think it's it's really
different than a normal race and you can
be the fastest Runners but if you fail
all those you want other tests you want
ones over competition okay
ha
[Music]
that's a great spin on the whole and we
try to make something that even if you
are the faster and the stronger Runner
it's not sure that you will win the game
the game I uh not only on the spot right
I think yeah yeah I like that approach I
I just the other day I did a podcast
with with Malcolm Gladwell who's a
writer I don't know if you're familiar
with him but he's also he's super into
running and he he always is thinking
about ways to change the way that we do
Sports to make them more interesting and
he had this idea that high school
cross-country teams should uh it should
be reconfigured such that it's not about
whoever wins the race for that team but
it's the combined time of like you know
the 10 people on the team so the the
slowest person on the team is just as
important as the fastest and so
everybody you're incentivized you know
as a team to cheer for the you know the
the least talented person or the least
well trained person on your team which
is similar to the idea that you just
shared like how can you even the playing
field and and make it kind of up for
grabs for anybody it's not just about
the best assets yeah and it's even even
without the activity if you run in a
team of free I think the the best team
will not be the the team of the best
free runner hrb the team we will take
care of the most of the field Runner
right because the third Runner the
slowest runner is the most important one
and if you don't take care of each other
you will be not able to finish and
that's why uh even at the edge station I
say okay you have to stop at least 25
minutes for everybody hmm
we've had the education will be more
cool moments Family can come and you
have time to discover and to discuss
with each other and you will have time
to take care of the third winner is
doing 25 minutes you don't take care of
the the other person of your group I
think it's a mistake because if you
arrive the first runner is easy it can
yes change your shoes absolutely Runner
I haven't made a message or okay ask and
change the nutrition strategy and edit
him and it will it can change a lot
because uh I think it's very important
to know that because then if they want
to make an ultra they will have more
experience and more ID about what can
happen in Eureka and I think all the
activity it looks like okay
tasting your cheeses this is
nothing to do it yeah but finally if you
think each activity will have a sense
for yourself or your team and for your
experience and your way on neutral and
that's what I we would like to to to
show to people at the end it's okay you
you did 10 activities you did three days
you don't need an ultra but with all of
that I think for your next Ultra you
will be more ready right and it makes it
more fun so that person who's trying
something for the first time will have a
positive experience that will make them
enthusiastic about like learning more
and we we also will that we will have
fun and we hope that they will have fun
to us all right we missed something
so this is you know a lot of people
perhaps expected you to show up at UTMB
again and go for a fifth win these days
dates coincide that makes that
impossible is it you know was that I
assume this is why you're not
participating in UTMB or is it just like
I did that I don't need to go back there
what is your relationship to that race I
I'm I'm not sure why would you go back
into the future because I did already uh
five times and I we need four times and
I did free time CCC so
I'm I'm not sure I will go back to
Champion I cannot promise it 100 percent
but uh maybe I will go back and a bit
different and with some other people I
don't know but uh for sure it's not my
goal to to be the first we need five
times or sixth time or even four times
because last year everybody say oh you
are here to be the first to win it four
times
uh okay if you want but not not that
wasn't your motivation no no that's not
my motivation and I think that's why I
win it four times it's just because it
was not my motivation but uh no I I for
me to try running means like some
different things some travel some
discouraging some some other racing I
think there's many many races in the
world and uh
yeah I think he's your team is it's
important it's a very nice way it's an
incredible race and even if people say
ah it's too crowdy my now there's too
much people and it's uh it's a big race
a big mess okay but
you Champions you can be and even River
race or without a race when you are here
and you say okay you have to to cross
three different countries you have to
made a loop around this amazing mundane
it's amazing it's very wonderful and if
you can uh I really enjoyed that that
part of the of the friends and of the
Alp and um
yeah for me it's when I think your team
beats uh it's very good good memories
and for sure I will be there again one
time but I'm not sure I will race again
to to warn it because uh
I I did it and uh I have many many years
or goals and uh and I I want to to
discover something else and to travel
and to make something different and and
I have many many plans in in my head for
the next fewer so yeah well I think it's
cool that you're always kind of
iterating and growing and and not afraid
to kind of let go of things to try new
things which kind of brings up the the
the wine making thing I mean for years
your wife and yourself
we're creating wine right in Beaujolais
region you've since moved to the
mountains but talk a little bit about
that like that's a world I know very
little about but feels like it would be
uh in all consuming kind of affair to
create great wine yeah it was a it was
very into and for you to MB it's just a
smaller joke I would like to add it's
just that I start I I don't want to go
back to UTMB because I would like I
really would like that an American
runner can we need to uh for the first
time
very sweet of you that's the whole quote
we'll take that out that's the that's
the thing you're gonna get quoted on and
then I just any American in particular
you might be thinking of all right so no
I I like the American winner but I guess
I have one of them not far from my house
and IOP it could be I think he's using
everything in his power right now to
make that happen just for you sure
it was um yes the one was really
passionated but to be honest at the
beginning
we were not thinking that this this job
is so is so fascinated and so complete
and so different every day we were just
thinking that uh okay we we we like each
other with my wife we get married since
11 years two days ago so so yeah we are
already closed and we really want to to
build something together but we were
thinking okay I'm physio I'm an
international Runner she works from an
array I work on my way
just too many things and we never see
each other and it's not the the way that
we want to spend our life so we have to
have a common projects and what we like
is to be out to be in the natural to
feel the you know the terror I don't
know if it's a good brand he has a land
soil yeah and The Roots
and it's very important for us and so we
were thinking maybe we will have some
animals maybe we will uh have a bed and
breakfast house and share something with
the people locally and something like
that and maybe we can have this
possibility to to take this Winery it's
a an old history with this family we
were family but not as close as we think
but
itself a lot for us but we were thinking
okay animals you have to be there every
day and bed and breakfast exactly the
same and with a international Runner
careers that may be possible so maybe
the winery could be the best option and
that's why we say okay
we will try this option and then we
discover this we we knew that we liked
the wine we like to test some different
wine even when we are in U.S or in
France it's just so interesting to see
that okay in that area it's totally
different that that otherwise there's a
mystery from this version to this
version I and we are really fascinated
about the taste and about the feeling
and the history and everything so we
knew that it would be something that
very pleasant for us but then we have we
will discover that
each season is totally different and
each moment of the season it's totally
different because you have to focus on
commercializing of communication of
creating the borders on the vinification
on the work on the vineyard and each
moment it's totally different and it was
so helpful for us to discover everything
and to play with that so it was a full
full-time job but it was so interesting
and we have an amazing 10 years on the
vineyard and and yes we really enjoy
that and we we developed some many many
projects about that like like doing the
pandemic we develop something like a bit
more ecological is to to bring the wine
from the valet to at to the mountain by
foot instead of helicopter oh wow it was
very interesting very hard yeah very
interesting but this project even if we
stop we we want to continue it and I was
there like on next last Monday like two
days ago to bring to the two different
and during the day and it was like eight
hours working with uh 30 kilo on your
backpack and it's so interesting to
bring the wine from the valet to the
Earth even if some other things that
came to the by helicopter at least the
wine came back by foot and it's so
interesting the idea is that for like
sustainability reasons just to say that
this is possible it's not just for
sustainability but it's just to show
people you bring directly from the
predictor to the consummator and even
it's true that there's a sustainability
but it's it's really important for us
but it's just people they will take a
glass of wine they know from where the
wine is coming they know how the wine is
coming to the Earth and then you are
with your friends in the mountain with
the sunset take your glass of wine it's
I think it's a totally different one
yeah yeah yeah yeah I can I can see that
and I know you were growing uh you
you're doing it organic or at least one
of them yeah yeah it was it was one of
the things that why we have to stop is
because it's uh it's a lot of cost and
it's a lot harder we are not the owner
of the of the land and uh it's maybe too
much uh too much money to continue in
our way for them and then with the kids
and it was too it means too much
traveling for me from the mountain place
where we are actually to the Beaujolais
so it's many many things that we say
okay yeah we did it for 11 years maybe
we it's time to switch from something
else and we really want to focus on that
event so it's it's many many reasons
that we we change but uh but this kind
of project with that we want to continue
it because it is very very interesting
and yeah tonight uh
I I don't know if you will test it
tonight but I have some wine for you
maybe you will taste it with your family
to enjoy it it's it's uh well it's a
different conversation but about my
relationship with wine but anyway
um
Beaujolais is I mean it's not that far
from Geneva right it's fairly close but
you're not in the mountains right so are
you in the US is not yeah it looks close
it's a couple hours in the car right
yeah it's two hours yes nothing not nice
it's been big butts uh but for you to
train day and it's
totally different yes yeah yeah yeah so
so you may so instead of having to go
back and forth with the kids it's like
let's simplify Our Lives we you move to
the mountains yeah and it's yeah because
I it means that uh we were living uh
in the budget place and in the
Performing place at a different moment
of the year so as they have to change
the school uh two times a year and for
them it's a I can understand that it's a
bit odd and that yes many many reasons
and now we live yes in a small village
in the in the earth of the Alps and 420
it's
really better for me and I think for for
life it's it's more sustainable and it's
more interesting for us
and uh yeah it was it was hard for when
you change something in your life it's
always hard to make the move but I think
we are we're happy with our new new
choice and
and I hope we will enjoy it for a long
time yeah and from a parenting
perspective I mean your kids are still
so young but to kind of raise them in
that mountain environment you know I
would assume on some level you're
exposing them to this you know the kind
of activities that you love uh they'll
grow up with that um they'll have their
own minds about what they want to do of
course but do you have a sense of
whether one or more of your kids is you
know prone to the kind of things that
you're that you like to do or is it too
early to tell yeah we don't want to push
themselves too much on what we did and
the competition approach because already
people do it for us
like your father and you will do that
that no no which way do it never works
out but it's true that they don't have
like a TV at home it's true that uh
they are always always a
International in the mountain and
there's not too many cars and there is a
yes it's a totally different life that
if you live in a city for sure and uh
it's a very small school there's a
there's not too many children and they
all know each other and and yeah during
winter time this key like two times or
three times a week which is cool and two
times our free time so we wave the club
and one time with me so it means that
they can ski like six times a week it's
just it's just yes yes it's it's sure
that they for sure they will be
fascinated about uh about snow about
Mountain about everything and and yeah
when there's they came with with us to
the Earth they are so happy to sleep in
the earth and they already made like 800
meters in Russian gain at six years old
because I have three three box of wines
on my backpacks so they know that hey I
cannot wear them so I said okay I have
to go by myself because my father are
already four Box of Rain so they did it
finally and sometimes they even did it
faster than us because with four box of
wine you are not so easy
so yeah it's sure that uh yeah the
Android I hope they enjoy the life in
the mountain but uh yeah that smiles
every day so it's okay and and the wine
even though you're not doing it anymore
I mean there's still you have plenty of
wine still to sell right like yeah yeah
for years to come so so do you have that
available at some of these races in
Europe like how does that how do you
distribute that yeah we try to just make
like a direct direct setting so directly
to the people so we choose like three to
four event every year not too much
because uh it's
it's important for us to take time to
discuss and to spend some time with
people so it's a it's been a lot of
energy
so we just choose like four to five uh
events every year to to set it and to to
share it with the people but yeah I
think for the next two to three years we
have a we have the possibility to sell
it
still said it and we we made some
different like
tri-runner box every year so we made we
made the last one and we will be
releasing like two months I think it
will be ready for for the end of the of
the season and it's a very interesting
one that which we try to relate to the
all the history of the last 10 years
it's a mix between running and fighting
the wine so we made a lot of of job and
news question about that so for us it's
uh it's a bit emotional that this last
this last box yeah so running and
drinking wine combined into one
experience
yes yeah and normally for people it's
not uh it's not like a good runner
approach or a good athletic approach but
uh now we we discuss a lot together and
you can understand that finally with my
way to train and my way to life it's
it's not impossible to have a winery and
to have a and to drink a glass of frying
idea of of your training and training
and be a top athlete because I think
it's important to say that if you spend
10 hours in the mountain then okay you
can arrive and drink nothing and just
eat some veggies and going to sleep
or otherwise you can say okay I run 10
hour and it was a very good Training and
I was with some friend in the mountain
and now I have to have a social moment
with them it could be a coffee or a
glass of wine or beer or whatever you
want but for me it's important to say
okay it was an amazing day and then we
when you will be in the race and you
should think okay
that training of 10 hour then I said to
my friend no I cannot come with you
because I have to make my campaigns and
I have to sleep early and I have to do
nothing and and you will remember when
it will be on moment to inside okay it
will be our training and then I don't
have a good moment with my friends I was
by myself in my room and it was out
again or you can remember okay it was an
art training but it was so good training
and then I have a nice moment with some
friends and we have a nice dinner and we
have a nice moment wow it was so good
and then you are in positive attitude
and you can continue and for me it's my
approach to say okay
okay it's advert I know it will be out
but at least I have this very nice
training in my bag and and so good to
think about that at this moment so
that's why I try to to enjoy that and
that's why I say to people okay I won't
say to you drink a bottle of wine just
one hour before the race but like one
week before or even two months before
when I saw people no I cannot test you
one I have UTMB in three months I say
wow three months before the race you
don't want to taste one glass of my wine
okay maybe you push too much pressure
yeah exactly and it it goes back to what
we were talking at the beginning about
like longevity in your career like if
you you have to enjoy what you're doing
if you're going to stay in it and
ultimately the more you're enjoying this
Pursuit as hard as it is uh the the kind
of higher you'll be able to reach like
you know but to live under such a strict
you know kind of rule book maybe you
have one great year but in five years
you're not going to want to do it
anymore I think if it's too hard for you
buddy it's not good but everybody is
different some people they like to
travel like a life like that like at
that life and they can do it for for the
trade no problem and I know somebody
like that and even kiriani I think he
his passion is not about like food or
social movement or something like that
but it's it's passion is like that but
people will say I really like wine but I
cannot have a glass of wine because in
six months I will do this right
how can this kind of people continue
this for 20 years it's impossible
because for me it's not possible so you
have to be like well balanced with what
you think what you feel and what you
love and then you can think about
longevity and I think for short distance
it's a different thing but for long
distance
I think it's a I think it's the best
approach to be well balanced and to to
enjoy what you do every day I think it's
very very important for me and so how
are you now 36 yes 36 so how long do you
imagine yourself being competitive in
the sport
I hope uh for many years but uh yes I
I try to do what I love and uh and I I
don't want to change my way of life so
if in five years
I don't know the level increase a lot
and on 100 miles is became more and more
athletic and more more competition and
more like you have to change your life
and stop to to have a normal life and
family beside your training to be able
to reach the top
it's no matter for me I will continue I
I hope I I will continue and I will do
it again maybe not at the first position
but
I I don't want to stop running and I
don't want to stop traveling and
discovering some new races and meet the
community like that yeah and to have
some project but maybe I won't be I
won't be the top in five to ten years
but I'm sure I will I I'm able to
continue to progress maybe I will
progress less than the
sub competitors but I'm shrike I'm able
to continue to progress
because I think uh
I continue to experience my slave my
just my my life and I'm sure I really
I will have some new things to discover
right you've created a life that's
conducive to the training but also to
the kind of Joyful pursuit of all like
everything seems like it's in a in a
nice balance that will allow you to
continue to do it whether you're able to
be on a Podium or not almost feels
secondary from the way that you
explained it yeah and um since I don't
know maybe 10 years no but why yeah I
think 10 years now I try to have some
projects of project uh in producing
other things of the races and I did we
discussed a lot about that with Jim
williamsley and someone was a runner I
and I'm sure even if it's not on on the
race or on classical race I'm sure
I will be able to continue some
different projects I I never been in
Malaya and I think it's some incredible
Monte universe and some incredible
project to do around there and I really
passionate seed when I I heard story
about no lands not far from there and uh
it will be so interesting to make it
like differently like with Jim maybe to
to spend some
some hours in the mountain like for 25
or 30 or 40 hours in the mountain
together and yeah I discussed with Tim
Tillerson he joined me on the Pacific
Crest on the John Muir Trail in 2017 Jim
was with me on the Pacific crystal in
2019 and
it's so interesting and there's a cool
other trade just over there and I have I
have ton of projects that I would like
to do in try running and uh I think it's
the most important goal for me it's more
important than winning that race or that
race or that race is just to wow what I
have to do in the next 10 years
plenty of things I think yeah yeah yeah
yeah
before we kind of round this out there
are plenty of Runners that that listen
to this show uh
uh and aspiring Runners people who are
thinking about perhaps their first Trail
race or their first ultra marathon so I
thought it'd be great if you could share
maybe some wisdom around
um
you know what what are some common
mistakes that people make that you see
in training for their first race or
um or in being kind of maybe too afraid
to sign up for something that seems
impossible to do like how do you think
about that or you know what would you
say to that person
yeah I think the progression is
something very very important I I know
that uh maybe it's because force of the
media of the people to say is the god
and things to do with 100 mice but you
cannot start your running carrier with a
10K and one year later at the start line
of when I'm with mice yes you can do it
and and maybe you can finish it but if
you think Longevity if you think
progression or you can
you can split from 10K to one and one
mice in one year yes if you should if
you take a look at that if you have a
look at on that it's not just possible
so I think the progression is really
important and to think that uh yes you
have time to do it because for me 100
miles is to dream
so if you achieve your dream too fast
then okay you can just have some
Wizardry but if it's a big dream
no matter if you take you one year to
your three or five years maybe it's it's
maybe a better dream if it's take long
time to achieve it and try that so I I
think it's very important to have this
kind of progression to have different
tastes to have different history to take
time to meet the people to discover
yourself there's a I I I uh yeah I've
even with my partner with cinnamon we
were since 10 euros to develop the
product and to test the product so it's
so interesting to test this kind of bags
of shoes what what is the battery for us
and the nutrition strategy and
everything I think it's so interesting
to test everything so people have to
take time to test everything to test
them send to discover yourself before
going to the one with mice but
but the second thing that you say is
true that wow 100 miles it looks like
impossible but not not I think 100 miles
is even more possible than a marathon
because in Marathon you have the
perspective of performance and of time
and maybe in New York Marathon it's a
bit different because it's okay I just
want to do New York Marathon no matter
the time but normally people and one
running marathons they want to put time
on one-on-one mice no matter the time
you just want to finish it for the first
one out to the last Runner it's the same
goal is just to achieve this adventure
and this journey and it's so hard and so
interesting to do but it's not
impossible because it's it could be just
working just running and if if you go it
slowly I'm sure it's possible but you
have to be really passionated about that
and you have to know why you do that if
you are at the start line of 100 my race
just because it's a bet with your friend
or just because you're a dream you're in
trouble and you say okay I made this bed
with my friend and now I'm here but I'm
not sure I want to be there okay don't
take the start because running
one-on-one nice it's it must be
something that you fit in your Earth and
and you are really motivated about that
because of course it will be hard but if
you know why you are here if it's a
dream
I'm sure it's possible to do it yeah
knowing your why
and patience right that idea of
progression really is about patience I
think so many people
really overestimate what they can do in
a year and they fight off more than they
can chew and then find out quickly
enough that you know that maybe that
wasn't possible and then they give up
and they miss the greater opportunity
which is understanding what's possible
with persistence and patience over an
extended period of time maybe it's 10
years but yeah
and you slowly slowly iterate on it in
that really non-sexy way that no one's
paying attention to like that's truly
how you accomplish these goals that seem
audacious yeah I think I started running
long distance in yes yes
right out of the bat and we're just
winning everything that you entered no
nice even for me and I was able to win
some big Ultra race it's taken me 10
years to to do it so 10 years is not
nothing so I I'm sure we can do it in
four or five ccl's but but uh yes four 5
CCO for people it's too long
and but but I think it's uh it's it's
not a big deal and to made a 100 my race
is not nothing and if you consider it
like okay it's just one word by mice
race you say I can do it so I will do it
in one year
no I think it's not a good approach why
not with my race it's not nothing and if
you think it's nothing
it will be too hard for you
that's a very wise thing to say yeah I
mean how about just start with can you
go out and walk around a mountain all
day you know like instead of thinking
about how fast you can run and how long
you can sustain a certain pace
yeah I think it's uh it's the best thing
to say just to say okay
no matter no matter the base no matter
the elevation no matter the distance and
everybody say about training uh what is
your middle age uh what is the distance
you're doing three I say I don't know
even for my event that we would create
in September we don't want to give the
distance we will say to people okay you
will have to spend five to six hours in
the mountain yeah but what what is the
distance I don't know
I don't know it's maybe I can give you
elevation gain maybe I can say you some
different thing but I don't know it will
depend your pace it will depend the
forecast it will depends on the terrain
everything but I don't know what would
be the distance it's just you have to be
able to spend like six hours of First
day and 11 hours a second day in the
mountain and then we will see with what
we what would be the distance but we we
don't know and I don't want to know
battle Drive Americans crazy but what's
great about that is it forces you to let
go of all of those attachments and
expectations like can you free yourself
from you know what you imagine it's it
is or it can or will be and just be in
the experience
which is really what it's about right
yeah yeah that's it's a good version
where do you uh where you know what do
you you have your idea of uh you know
what you want to do with these races
that you're creating but where do you
see the future of trail running and
ultra running like 10 years from now you
know how are you thinking about like the
new generation of young Ultra Runners
who are coming up and what is that world
going to look like in the not too
distant future
face it's hard to say because I I'm so
happy that there's more and more and
more people practicing traveling but in
in a sustainable way you can say okay if
it's more and more event and more and
more thing organized and if if you start
a race now you are 100 people and in 10
years you are 10 000 people I think it's
too much for the track it's too much for
for everything so that's why with the
event and that's why I think with the
organizer and Runner we say okay
tray scenario it's it's good I think
it's it's good for the body and it's
good for the planet too because I I can
do like 10 Ultra 20 in a year but it's
mean that 10 travel
you should do only two it's already two
travel okay it's a lot but it's a need
to travel for international athlete I
think it's it's a minimum that I have to
do to meet the community and to to be
there uh
at the top of the International race but
it's a need to races and that's why I I
try to discuss with people that uh
there's only there's not only a life
when you have a big number you can make
things by yourself and that's why in my
event and that's why when I discuss with
you and something like that I say a lot
that you have to experience yourself
alone in the mountain to discover
yourself to
to understand how when you go in a moon
chain you have to to take care of the
forecast of your equipment about the map
about everything and you have to take an
edge lamps you have to take a service
blanket and you have to yes
to take care from each other if you are
in a group and I think it's very
important and I think in 10 years
I'm sure that there will be more and
more and more try winner but maybe
maybe less races and maybe people they
will do it by themselves and they will
organize their Adventure by themselves
and and with that just
No Limit because you can imagine
your personal adventure and what is more
relevant for you and because uh may I
say that my season is from July to
October but
every place in the world are different
and every people are different so you
have there's no definition of traveling
because you can do it uh along the
coasts you can do it in the mountain you
can do it in the middle of whatever you
decided to be yeah and me I like when
it's in the mundane but for some people
they prefer to do it in a single tray
flat above the ocean and everybody is
different and everybody have some
different tastes or with that with that
Evolution everybody can build their own
adventure by themselves alone long
distance short distance cause distance
maintain cost challenge
and what is important for me is that
people they can discover themselves they
can discover the nature and they are out
from some long beans and mountain and
people say yeah it's not sustainable
driving and too many race I mean even
yeah but
you can just practice driving without
any race without any event and by
yourself and
and I think it's a good approach and I I
would like to
say to people try to test it play with
that and for me it's supersonated since
more than 20 years and
and then so I I'd like to push people to
say okay try it and you will see it it's
possible to do things that you are not
thinking it's possible it's just 20
years ago
for me doing like artwork 100 it's just
unbelievable right and 20 years later I
was able to run it and to have the
record on that way so nothing is
impossible so you can you can do it and
and the Victory is not just
about winning is just just accomplish
your dreams so this is what is
interesting in try running a new trial
is that everybody has his own Victory
and everybody can share the same green
and the same Adventure because uh
when we are on the start line of The
radok 100
the winner of the race since the last
winner of the race
have the same dream it's just to
to finish the loop and to see silvertone
again no matter the place we just want
to finish it and accomplish it and I
think this is unique in all of all of
the other sport yeah yeah that's really
that's beautifully put I mean there is
this
inherent uh sort of paradox with the
growth of trail running because the
roots of it and and what is so alluring
about it is that connection with nature
in that and that kind of the Solitude of
it all and the you know the kind of
Silence just you and your breath and the
wind and whatnot but as these races and
interest in this world continue to grow
suddenly these you know you're you're
sleeping in a tent at the starting line
and there's two people there or whatever
now there's you know like media and it's
like money and all the commercialization
and all of that which obviously is
antithetical to the whole Spirit of the
entire thing but I think what is great
about these self-styled Adventures is
that that's where people's heads are at
right I mean the pandemic when all the
races ended everybody had to get
creative and suddenly you saw this
explosion of people just saying well I
don't need to wait for permission for
this race to happen I'm going to go out
and like do my own thing and now I feel
like there's a lot of momentum behind
that type of of endeavor and it doesn't
have to be in fkt it could just be hey I
have a trail in my you know a mile from
my house that I've never gone on before
let's see what we can do
is a thing
too and just trying to do something is
is I think something very good and even
for me when I when I start a skg
okay so if KT must be a good excuse with
all the partner and everything but uh in
my for my feelings the best thing is
just to try it and to do it and okay the
race is cloudy it's many people it's uh
it's too much sometimes but it's if I
did two race it's 40 hour and it's 800
hour of training for 40 hours so it's
not a lot
right
um fantastic man well I think uh that's
a good place to kind of end it for today
um I'm excited to watch erase it at Hard
Rock seems like you're in good spirits
and your body is cooperating so I think
it's going to be exciting to watch that
Showdown yeah I should be it would be so
nice in any way what
what's happened we would see and no
matter I just saw Peter Breezer and uh
and and to come back there and uh for me
it was a good moment to to share it with
you at least then uh and so happy to to
make this experience and uh and I'm sure
I will have some memories from from the
next adventure yeah very cool well let's
continue this conversation at a later
date I'd love to have you back on and uh
I really appreciate you bringing all
your thoughtfulness and experience to
this conversation it's really cool so
um what you're doing is really inspiring
I think it it really uh inspires all of
us to kind of reach a little bit further
and deeper and you know kind of what you
said about how it took you 20 years to
get where you're at it's very easy to
look at someone like yourself and say
well he just it it's easy for him he's
you know Built For This and all of that
and maybe there's some truth in that but
you know to understand like the passion
that you have for the sport the
dedication and just the the love of the
outdoors and the you know joyful
expression that you you know bring to
everything that you do I think is
uplifting for for everybody to hear so
thank you for that
thank you very much cool all right uh if
people want to learn more about you
what's the E where do you like to direct
people I mean your Instagram account is
that the best place yeah I try to to be
myself and my social media account uh
yes of course and yeah I can I can meet
each other on the trade one day I oh but
yes uh I try to to work a bit on my
social media to to share my passion and
my values and I hoped once well to to
you for and I'll have links up to all
that stuff in the show notes so just
check that out and uh thanks Francois
thank you he continued cheers
face
[Music]